yeah the calmness of a killer we just go
to prison obviously again wow what are
you doing something to anyone else yeah
well you don't know there's four people
this is Damian bandel handing himself
into police after the brutal murders of
his partner her two children and one of
their friends he had a history of
violence but at the time of the killings
he was on probation serving a suspended
prison sentence for arson
now a damning reports by his Majesty's
inspectors of probation has highlighted
how the services handling of bendel's
case fell well below the necessary
standard that the risk he posed had been
badly underestimated
we found that at every stage of the
Probation Services assessment and
management of Damien Bendel the quality
of that work was of an unacceptable
standard bandel was living under curfew
with his girlfriend Terry Harris and her
two children John Paul and Lacey Bennett
despite previous convictions for violent
crime and allegations of domestic abuse
made by a former partner he murdered all
three as well as eleven-year-old Connie
gent who was having a sleepover at the
house
the probation service allowed Bendel to
give this address to the courts as the
place where he would serve out his
five-month curfew without first speaking
to Terry Harris without visiting the
property and without carrying out any
domestic abuse inquiries
the review highlighted the fact that
bandel had previously served three
prison sentences between 2011 and 2019
two for violent robbery one for
assaulting a prison officer it says that
Bendel was incorrectly assessed as
posing a medium risk to the public and a
low risk to Partners and to children in
reality it says he should have been
assessed as being of high risk of
serious harm
pre-census reports for his asking
conviction also failed to include
safeguarding or domestic abuse checks
the failings essentially meant that the
judge who gave bandel the suspended
sentence which allowed him to commit the
murders did not have the full facts
about the risk he posed Fraser Maude Sky
News killer Marsh